Hello, and welcome to your second drink of Season 5, Episode 25, Broke, directed by Steve Correll. Yes, Jenna, you did a whole fast fact about Steve directing. And I have a question for you. What? Now that you haven't done any fast facts in a while, do you miss the fast facts? No. No, I do not miss them, but I do not hate them. I mean, you enjoy doing them for a while.
A handful of years. Yeah. And then it was a grind. Yeah. And when I revisit our breakdowns, I am really proud of them. I'm really glad I did them. But I am no longer triggered by the term fast fact. So I am making some progress.
So if I just called you and left on your voicemail, fast fact. No, that might do me in. Okay, all right. Don't do that. Okay. Well, I thought all three of your fast facts for this episode were fantastic. One of them was about Duncan. Donuts because Michael says, time to make the donuts. And we got this letter from Amanda G.
Who said, hey ladies, I was just listening to the broke episode and your fast fact about donuts made me reach out. My husband is a donut maker, aka the donut daddy. And he has a small independent donut shop here in Virginia. He helped open with a friend. He is just like the Dunkin' Donuts spokesman Michael Vail. He usually is in bed by 6 p.m. and he's out the door. between 11 p.m. and 1 a.m. Wow. I know. His usual day is a 2 a.m. to 7 a.m. He has his own donut mix he worked on and he comes up with crazy toppings and flavors, etc. He has been making donuts for the last few years and found his passion. He is such a hardworking, caring person and I love him so much. So if you find yourself on your food tour driving through Virginia, stop into the Daily Fix and New Kent. Donuts, breakfast, sandwich. Me's and burgers. We would love to see y'all. I love the show and also a huge office fan. Keep up the great work, ladies. You're amazing. Aw. I know. Do you know what those hours made me think of besides making donuts? What? Is all the people who do like the Today Show? How I think they get up at like 3 a.m. and they go into work and they're live on the air at the crack of dawn and then their whole day is done by 10 a.m.
Yeah. Think also about the hair and makeup teams and the crew. crew that get there before the on-camera people, their day must start at like two in the morning. Yeah. And I remember talking to someone about how they would go to bed around like 6 or 7 p.m. But then my question is, well, what about like when I see them out at events, like evening events, charity events, how do they do it? I don't know. I can barely make it to an event that starts at 7, let alone if I have to get up at 2 a.m. I don't know. I don't want to go to any events anymore. I know. You know, event I want is the event that happens on my couch. Oh, I love that event. All events on my back porch, making me so happy.
I will dress up for my back porch. Yeah? I mean, I'm just saying. Yeah. I would do that. I would come downstairs. My commute. Oh, my commute. Well, listen, this is a pretty fantastic breakdown overall, lady. And at this point, our breakdowns, I just need to say we had gotten pretty darn good at uncovering information. And I could not find much that we did not mention the first time around. But I did find one thing, which is that the original title for this episode was Delivery Day. It wasn't broke. It was Delivery Day. Oh, well, you know what?
I actually think it's good that they changed that because delivery day is making me think that someone's having a baby. Yeah. Right? Yeah. So I think broke is better. Same. A big part of this story is that Michael Scott Paper Company is going broke. And in revisiting this episode, it got me wondering about how long it typically takes for a new business to succeed or fail.
Oscar is trying to give Michael advice about this outside of the warehouse, give him like a reality check. But I wanted to look into it a little bit. So I did a mini dive for this second drink. What do you think of that? I mean, I'm here. All right. Well, first of all, there are a lot of different kinds of businesses, and they actually all have different projected success failure rates. So most small businesses take two to three years to become profitable.
So Michael is, he needs to be in that zone. I don't think he's thinking two to three years. No, he was thinking immediate. Yeah. Yeah. According to data from the U.S. Bureau of Labor Statistics, roughly one in five new businesses closed within the first 12 months. Most small businesses fail because of poor cash flow management, which is exactly the Michael Scott paper company's problem.
Incidentally, according to the internet, one of the most reliable small businesses that almost always turns a profit and is successful, laundromats. Huh. Yeah, so it's too bad Michael didn't start a laundromat. That would have been more aligned with his expectations. I always wonder about parking garages. Now, we live in a big bustling city, and, you know, you think about a parking garage, like, okay, you're going to draw some lines on some concrete, you know, parking spaces. Yeah.
You're going to have to pay for the little kiosk in the arm. Yeah. I mean, you also have to pay for the whole structure. That's a lot of real estate. The rent of the structure. So I think you need a lot of upfront money for that, unlike a laundromat. Right. Which is a smaller footprint.
I don't know. every time I drive past a parking garage, I'm like, bet they're making a lot of money. I do. I do find it to be a little bit of a hustle. Don't get me started on having to pay for parking at places like hospitals, which you have to do in Los Angeles, because I will not recover. It'll be a soapbox I don't get off of. We'll put a pin in it. Put a pin in it. We're going to have a, we call BS on parking episode. But before we get to our second drink, I did want to mention one thing here. In our breakdown, I talked to. how there was an alternate cold open of Michael oversleeping and rushing into the office late. It's very funny, and they added it back into the superfan version. In fact, the superfan version of Broke has eight more minutes of footage, so a lot got added back. Yes, I saw that. I actually went to see if I could see the cold open you mentioned, and it's very funny for anyone
who wants to check it out. All right, you guys. Well, here is our second drink of Broke. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Everybody.
Good morning, everyone. I always say good morning. It's because we're here in the morning. Because we're here in the morning. Every time I do it, Jenna gives me this look like, Angela, it might not be morning for everyone else. Don't stop. Don't stop saying good morning.
Should we talk about the episode? We're going to be breaking down today. I would love nothing more. I found this episode hilarious. This snuck up on me. Yes, it was a sneaker-upper. I absolutely loved it. You know, you look back and you think about the office and all the, like, sort of obvious ones come to mind.
Right. But this is so incredibly good. It should be on all the lists. It should. And there was more to it that didn't make it in. That is so delicious. and I can't wait to share that. What we're talking about is broke.
Season 5, episode 25, written by Charlie Grandi, and directed by our very own Steve Correll. How fun was that? That was amazing. That is my fastback number one. Oh, do it. But we should start with a summary. Oh, we should.
I need my order. Go in order. Okay. I need to say good morning. You need to go in order. It's who we are. It's who we are. All right.
The summary is exhausted from making their own deliveries, the Michael Scott Paper Company is steadily gaining clients due to their very low prices, but it turns out they're going broke in the process. Yeah. Meanwhile, Dunder Mifflin is desperate to negotiate a buyout because they have lost several important clients to Michael Scott Paper Company. But Michael has other ideas. I was so impressed and also scared by all of Michael's tactics when he...
Gets out of the elevator and he's like doubled over and he's like, I'm really afraid I'm afraid I'm not going to say we're going to be able to do it. It's so funny. All right, fast fact number one. Steve Correll directed this episode. It was his first time directing the show and his first time directing in general. He was so prepared. Oh my gosh. Yes.
I was so impressed with him. We talked to Randy Cordray about that and he said Steve's work ethic was incredible. that he was totally prepared. He had great ideas, great energy. He said he was so respectful of every crew position. He wanted everyone's input to make the scenes better. He said Steve totally immersed himself in the prep of this episode. I loved him as a director.
I have one little moment I'll share when we get there of a note he gave me that I was like, totally changed the scene for me. Well, I traded some messages with Steve about this episode. I just wanted to know, Steve, what was that like for you to direct all of us? Because he was, I believe, the first cast member to step into a directing role. Oh, I think you're right. And here's what Steve said. This is a quote. It was like being the conductor of a world-class orchestra. Aw. Everyone was so good. It was pretty easy. Aw. Well, we got a fan question from Bridget R. who said, what was a? it like having a main cast member direct and did it present any challenges? Well, a little bit
because, you know, Steve couldn't watch the scene when he was performing in the scene. Right, right. And the week before you direct an episode, the director normally preps the episode. And that sort of involves meeting with each of the different department heads to make decisions about the locations, about the props, the wardrobe, camera setups. And this was a little tricky for Steve because Steve spent the prior week acting in an episode. I remember he had to sort of squeeze things in. Like he'd be in a scene and then he would have to like hop on to like a van to go location scout. Yes. Yeah. Randy said luckily the Michael Scott Paper Company storyline was such that Steve generally had a couple days off each week for when we would shoot up at Dunder Mifflin.
And so he immersed himself in prep for those two days. But it's true. I would notice there would be this van waiting outside at lunch and they would go scout a location for a half hour. Yeah. And then he'd come back and jump into scenes. Well, I also spoke with Randall Einhorn, our cinematographer, who said he remembers Steve was very focused on characters and actor-performer as a director. So I guess this will come up in the note that he gave you, Angela. Yeah. But he said he was just so respectful. He was so devoid of any ego. And that's how I remember working with Steve.
He just made you better naturally. He's just someone that makes everything better. Yeah. You know, you know those people. You're like, gosh, I feel so great whenever I'm around them. I took this leadership seminar once, and they said that a great leader is a person where, like, you leave your interaction with that person and you feel more confident and better and you notice yourself more, that that is your goal if you're ever in a leadership position, not for you to show off how interesting and powerful you are. Right. But to try to empower other people.
Well, that's definitely Steve. That's definitely Steve. Guys, yeah, I'm that person who went to leadership seminars on the weekends. I wasn't going to say anything. I'm that gal. I wasn't going to say anything. Sign me up. As you said it, I thought, oh, I would have just loved to know Jenna then.
I saw this thing someone posted on Instagram, Jenna, it made me laugh so hard. I'm going to paraphrase it, but it said something like, everyone in life deserves the person they cannot sit next to in a serious situation. And I just think about if I had taken that leadership class with you. We wouldn't have been able to sit next to each other. Listen, that leadership class was great because I had a really hard time finishing things. I would start projects all the time. Scripps, a one-woman show. I don't even know what, even a home project.
I was very good at having ideas and doing the first three steps, but I wasn't a finisher. And this leadership seminar was a little bit focused on finishing what you start. I tell you what, I finish what I start now. That's so good. I'm all about it. I'm like, there's got to be experts out there who can teach me skills. How is I supposed to be born knowing how to do everything? I'll go to therapy.
I'll go to your leadership seminar. Sign me up. All right. Fast fact number two is called awards. Because our writer. Charlie Grandi was nominated for a Writers Guild Award for Best Screenplay of an Episodic Comedy for this script, and Steve Carell used this episode as his submission for the Emmys for Outstanding Lead Actor in a Comedy Series. Well, I know Steve didn't win, which remember I was so mad about.
I think I said profanity and there was a camera on us. Steve never won an Emmy for his portrayal of Michael Scott. How is that sentence a thing I can say? I don't know. Wait, did Charlie win? Charlie didn't win either. Well, son of a. I know.
You know, it's crazy. That got me thinking about how you have to submit yourself for awards. I feel like that's something not a lot of people know. We did. Yeah, and it costs money. Sometimes the network will pay for it. Right. But I think as an actor, you pick one or two episodes that you think best represent your performance.
You also pick your category. You can decide if you want to be submitted for lead or supporting. I know. I was very excited because season four of the office, there was an article that said I was a dark horse for a nomination for supporting actress in a comedy because I had that whole great, you know, arc with sprinkles and all of that. Yes. And I was so excited.
That was enough for me. I mean, I realized that like some people were able to have sort of a big machine behind them campaigning. but just the fact that this one person saw my performance, I cut out the magazine. I saved it. I totally get that, Ang. I was only nominated the one year for season two. Yeah. And occasionally, though, my name would come up on those lists. Yes, it's so exciting. Yeah. What's your fast fact number three? Fast fact number three is called Time to Make the Donuts. Do I get a donut? Did you make donuts?
No, I wish I had, though. I know you love a donut. I do. I should have known. I can't say donut and not provide you with a donut. You literally said it's time to make the donuts. Oh, no. This is not a Scotch and Splenda. I know.
You got me thinking it's a Scotch and Splenda moment. No, this is a little mini deep dive that I found incredibly charming based on the fact that Michael says it's time to make the donuts. Oh, the expression. Yes. Do you remember that commercial? It was from the 80. It actually ran from 1981 all the way to 1997, and it was for Dunkin' Donuts.
Do you remember it? Well, I was overseas until 84. Okay. This, by the way, is the thing my husband loves to tease me about. He said, Ange, you can't say you were in Indonesia for everything, okay? But there's some pop culture that's lost on you. Yes. Okay.
Because I grew up without television. Is that crazy until I was a teenager? Wow. I know. And then you wound up on television. And then I was obsessed with television. I bet. It's like the kid that, like, their parents don't let them have any sweets and then they come to your house and they raid your pantry. Yeah. I became, like, obsessed with television. Well, let me bring you up to speed. Okay. Fred the Baker was a character played by actor Michael Vail in these Dunkin' Donut commercials. Okay. And he was known for his catchphrase, time to make the donuts. So it would just be him, like all day, coming in and out of his door saying, time to make the donuts. I actually have an audio clip of it. Oh, I need to hear it. Time to make the donuts. Duncan donuts are always fresh. I made the donuts. We make them at least twice every day. Time to make the donuts. Not a few kinds like supermarket is.
The donuts. Time to make the donuts. But up to 50-2 varieties. The donuts. Time to make the donuts. I made the donuts. Dunkin donuts, up to 52 varieties fresh day and night. No supermarket can say that. So Fred the Baker had to make all those donuts, lady. I have so many questions because I could only hear it and not see it. It sounds like he's getting really tired.
He's tired. He's making donuts in the rain. Time to make the donuts. Because he's always making the donuts. Yeah. Well, this commercial was named one of the five best commercials of the 80s by the Television Bureau of advertising. Fred the Baker was so popular that when Duncan Donuts decided to finally retire this character, they surveyed customers to see how they might react. Well, customers said they would
let Fred retire, but only if, like, Fred, the character was treated like an honored friend and employee. So, Duncan Donuts created an official retirement celebration for him, which included a parade in Boston and a free donut day. They served over six million customers. It was September 22nd, 1997. Wow. But listen to this. After the actor who played Fred the Baker, after Michael Vail died in December of 2005, Duncan Donuts ran a commercial celebrating him that included like an in-memory of. And today, the catchphrase, time to make the donuts, is printed on the side of all Dunkin' Donut boxes in memory of Michael and his character of Fred the Baker. Aww. So if you get a box of Dunkin' Donuts and you see that on the side, that's why.
That's so sweet. You know, I think Dunkin' Donuts was more of an East Coast chain for a long time. Because I know whenever I flew to New York, I got very excited because there was a Dunkin' Donuts by baggage claim. And I would always go get a donut while I waited for my suitcase. Yeah, we had Dunkin' Donuts in St. Louis growing up, and my dad would go every Sunday. And I always wanted the strawberry iced. I love that one. That was my favorite.
I love that one, too. Now, during the office, there was no Dunkin' Donuts on the West Coast. And John Krasinski had this idea that he wanted to open up the first Dunkin' Donuts in L.A. Did he really? Yes. He was really into this for a while. And he tried to get Conan O'Brien to go in on it with him. Oh, my God.
This was a whole thing. Could you imagine if Conan and John owned a Dunkin' Donuts? That was the plan. And I don't know why it fell apart or if this was just like a daydream. But he talked about it all the time. He wanted to open a Dunkin' Donuts franchise in L.A. And you know what? Now they're here.
And whenever I pass by them, I wonder, is John like super. pissed because he had that idea. That was John Krasinski's idea. To bring it to the West Coast. Yes. Well, that's all I got for fast facts, lady. Well, I found them delightful and now I want a donut. Sorry, I really should have brought some Dunkin' Donuts in. Clearly, what was I thinking? I think we should go to break and we'll come back and get into this episode. I love it. We've got a quick recommendation today that we think you are going to love. Yes, our friends over at How We Made Your Mother Podcast, just dropped an incredible episode with the one and only. Bob Odenkirk.
Yes. And the behind-the-scenes stories that they share in this episode are insane. So first of all, did you know that how I met your mother is accidentally responsible for the creation of a character on Breaking Bad? No, that is crazy. But it's not just TV trivia. Bob also gets really personal. He talks about parenthood. He talks about finding.
the right amount of fame and finding his lane as a dramatic actor, even though he started in comedy. You guys, it is such a funny, insightful, and moving conversation. Head over to your favorite podcast app right now and search for the Bob Odenkirk episode on How We Made Your Mother. You don't want to miss it. All right. We're back. This episode opens with Pam, Michael, and Ryan making paper deliveries. Yeah. And incidentally, I found out the work. title for this episode was delivery day. Yes, thank you, Randy, with those nuggets. Well, you know what, Michael starts the day at 4.30 in the morning with a prank. He pulls up to get Ryan, and then as Ryan gets in, he pulls up forward, and he pulls forward, and Ryan's just like, ugh, Jenna, that would drive me crazy.
Yeah. I don't need people that peppy that early. No. It's too peppy. We got a fan question from Tyler B, who said this. My friend and I have watched the open scene with Michael inching the delivery van forward while Ryan tries to get in over and over. At 46 seconds, we cannot figure out if Michael says, I lied or denied to Ryan. It's denied. He says the captions say denied, but I'm not convinced because it almost sounds like delied. Do you know?
Well, we had the script. What did it say? It was not a scripted moment. Oh, of course. not. Of course they were playing around a little bit. I hear I lied, but I hear Steve's. Steve has this funny delivery he does sometimes where he like laughs at the beginning of a line. And he'll hold out a vowel. So I hear da lied, meaning like the duh is like part of his laugh. Well, gosh, I just think I need to hear it. I need to hear it. And then I'm going to decide what I hear. And I think we should put
a poll in our office ladies pod stories. I agree. I lied. It's I lied. He's like, I lied. I got to hear it again. I got to hear it again. Die lied. Oh my gosh.
It's definitely I lied because he's saying I won't do it again. Yes. And he's laughing. It's I lied. It's not denied. The subtitles are wrong. Completely. It's definitely not denied.
But it is like, I lied. Yeah, yeah. It's a little laugh. It's a catch at the top. It's a little bit of a delight. Tyler, I hope that that has helped you guys. We took that on. We took it very seriously.
We did. We did. Well, then Michael's got to go get Pam. He pulls outside and lays on the horn. Did you ever have a friend like that? I carpooled with a friend in high school who would lay on the horn. And my dad was like, all right, you got to tell her. Yes.
None of that. It's early. Yes. That was our carpool. You would go in the person's driveway, and you want to just give it like a bup-b-b-b-b-b-b-b. Yeah. Not a b-b-b-b-b-h. Exactly.
We got a lot of fan mail about these pickup scenes. One person said when Michael beeps the horn of the van, you can see the top-right corner of the neighbor's light turning on. They really like that detail. People also wanted to know, were these scenes really recorded at 4.30 and 5 in the morning? No, we shot these at night. What we would do is we would shoot all day at the studio. And then we would pack up and drive out to these locations to do like the early morning shots. So it was actually just evening.
I checked in with Randy to refresh my memory. He said we had to do this over two days because we never wanted to shoot too late into the evening because then we'd have to start later the next morning. And then you have to give the crew and the cast their turnaround. And then you guys, that becomes a domino effect. Then every day starts later and later. And then you get into one of those, what we call a Friday-day situation. Fratter-day. Frater-day?
Frater. Frat. Frat. Like sat-ter-day, but fr-a-from Friday. So fratter-day. Well, I've always called it Friday because you go F-R-I-D and then you go into Saturday. You, I believe, would be the only one who's saying Friday. Everyone else is saying friday.
Mm-hmm. in the biz. Well, guys, is it any surprise that I've been saying it wrong? I guess I could stand corrected, but I feel pretty confident. I will be texting a few of our friends when we wrap. All right, why don't you tell us more about how you shot these scenes? You obviously did one day was the Ryan pickup and then the next day was like the Pam pickup. No. What? One day was at Michael's condo. Okay. You know, at the opening shot. At the beginning, right? The other night, we did both Ryan's house and Jim and Pam's house because the location for Ryan's house was just a few houses down the block from Jim and Pam's house on Calvert Street in Van Nuys. Oh.
And the people who live next to the house that we used for Jim and Pam's house let us put a PA up in their bedroom to flip on the light switch. They were very good sports, Randy said. And that's not all, Angela. I also got a ton of fan questions about the van. Because Pam has that talking head where she says they got it at a used car lot. And they think that it says, Alleluia, Church of Scranton in Korean on the side of the van. People wanted to know, what did it really say? It said, Alleluia, Church of Scranton in Korean.
Our graphics artist Michael Marcus designed the logo. And they had it made into a large, like, stick-on decal that they put on the side of the van. So it really did say that. I love that because I love our show's attention to detail. I have a question for you, Jenna. Yes. In the next beat of this cold open, you're like, gosh, I could really use some coffee. And Michael's like milk and sugar.
And you're like, yes, thank you. And you take a big old swig and it's actually milk and sugar. And Michael says he drinks it every morning. Yeah. What did you really drink? It's just water. Please say it was just water. It was water.
Thank goodness. But I really sold it. You did. When I was rewatching this episode, I watched that moment. And I was like, that's good acting. I did a good job. It is good acting because I thought. I should put that on my Emmy submission.
You should. Because when I watched it, I thought, I wonder if Jenna was like, you can put milk and sugar so I react honestly or something, if you got kind of method. But you did what I did about running. Yeah. You just faked it. I'll just fake it. Fake it.
I'm an actor. I can do it. You can do it. And I did. And you sold it. So now Pam and Ryan are going to be unloading the paper. And I want to say if you think. things. Did you notice that I'm wearing a pencil skirt? I did. Did you see what the boys are wearing?
I did. Pam is wearing a hoodie and sneakers, but a pencil skirt. And I think with panty hose at 4.30 in the morning. Yes. To unload paper out of a van. Yes. Pam. Hmm. Our NBC executives. Correct. I guess that note about Pam being in pencil skirt. Wow, that really carries. Oh, I want to tell you also in the scene, a woman tries to get on the van. Yes. And the woman who gets on the bus was played by Clara Sooyung and the person who played the warehouse supervisor, who's with Michael, was played by Isabel Hubman. And I remember both of them were super awesome because we actually shot this really early in the morning. This one you did do early. We did. We got there. Oh my gosh, we were shooting by 645. Wow. And so I remember like we were all legitimately tired, but we also got finished really quickly.
So it was fun. Well, you know, Jenna, this was not the original cold open for the episode. Really? Truly. Tell me more. I will. Here was the original cold open. This is how the cold open was in the shooting draft.
It is the Dundra Mifflin office parking lot early morning. we hear a screech in the parking lot. The camera pushes in to find Michael with wet hair frantically parking and sort of running in. And he says, I'm late, I'm late, I'm late. Barges into the Dundermifflin bullpen, goes right into his office. And he's like, sorry, sorry, sorry, everyone. I'm overslapped, totally unexcusable. And he goes in his office and shuts the door.
Aaron and the rest of the office are very confused. Jim looks to camera and he says, this is a surprise. Michael's almost never late, and he hasn't worked here in four weeks. And then there's this brief scene between Jim and Michael, where Jim says, hey, what are you doing here? And Michael's like, oh, I owe everyone a huge apology. Did anyone notice I was late? And Jim says, I think they're just surprised you came at all. And then this plays out with Charles coming in and Aaron going, that's him. Like he's some intruder. Right. And then Michael realizes he's really embarrassed and he leaves. And Aaron's like, was I supposed to stop him? He seems so
亚伦和办公室里的其他人感到非常困惑。吉姆看着镜头说，这太让人意外了。迈克尔几乎从不迟到，而且他已经四周没在这儿上班了。接着是吉姆和迈克尔之间的一小段戏，吉姆说，嘿，你在这儿干什么？迈克尔就说，哦，我欠大家一个巨大的道歉。有人注意到我迟到了吗？吉姆说，我觉得他们只是惊讶你居然来了。然后查尔斯走了进来，亚伦喊道，就是他。就好像他是某种闯入者。对。接着迈克尔意识到自己非常尴尬，于是他离开了。亚伦说，我是不是该拦住他？他看起来那么
confident. And then there's this last little moment where Michael goes downstairs to the Michael Scott Paper Company and he's like, I'm sorry, I'm late, but only Pam is there, but Ryan is late. It's so funny. Randy told us that there were a ton of deleted scenes from this episode. And I bet what they did was they cut this cold open and they made what we were, what would have been the top of this episode a cold open. Yes. Because this is not a standalone cold open. This relates to the rest of the episode. It's, you know, deliveries and Michael Scott Paper Company. Yeah. So that's really interesting. They must have had to do that for time to squeeze more stuff in. There was a lot in the shooting draft that did not make it in. Wow. So as this episode opens,
自信。然后是最后一个小片段，迈克尔下楼来到迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司，他说，对不起，我迟到了，但里面只有帕姆，瑞安却迟到了。这太搞笑了。兰迪告诉我们，这一集里有大量的删减镜头。我敢打赌，他们做的事是剪掉了这个片头前情，然后把本来应该是本集开头的片段做成了片头前情。是的。因为这不是一个独立的片头前情。这与本集的其余部分有关。你知道的，就是送货以及迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。是的。所以这真的很有趣。他们为了腾出时间塞进更多内容，肯定不得不这么做。拍摄剧本里有很多内容都没能播出来。哇。所以当这一集开始时，
Charles Minor is going to walk into the Dundermifflin bullpen and announce that, that they have now lost 10 clients to Michael Scott Paper Company. Yeah, that's a huge dent in their business. It really is. Charles is going to have a talking head where he says he does not know what to do to inspire people. And the camera's going to pull back. You're going to see Dwight hovering over his shoulder. I just want to point out that Dwight is still wearing his long sleeve white shirts
查尔斯·米纳走进邓德米夫林的办公大楼，宣布他们现在已经有10个客户被迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司抢走了。是的，这对他们的业务来说是一个巨大的打击。确实如此。查尔斯有一个面对镜头的独白，他说他不知道该如何激励大家。然后镜头拉远。你会看到德怀特悬在他的肩膀上方。我只想指出，德怀特仍然穿着长袖白衬衫，
with the sleeves that are too short because you can see his full watch. It is exposed on his wrist. His sleeves are too short. It's official. We agree with you, Jenna. We agree. His sleeves are too short. Okay, thank you.
袖子太短了，因为你能看到他的整块手表。它露在手腕外面。他的袖子太短了。官方宣布了。我们同意你的看法，珍娜。我们同意。他的袖子太短了。好的，谢谢。
But before this talking head ends, Angela is going to enter the room to talk about these expense reports. Yes. And all right, this is the scene I was talking about earlier where Steve gave me a note that changed how I delivered this line. And it was so fun for me to rewatch and remember. Angela comes in and she goes, Charles, I got your memo about the expense reports. Thank you. And Steve was like, what if almost in Angela's mind, this was like a personal memo to her.
但在这次独白结束之前，安吉拉走进了房间，准备讨论这些费用报销单。是的。好吧，这就是我之前提到的那场戏，史蒂夫给了我一个建议，改变了我台词的表达方式。对我来说，重新观看并回忆起来真是太有趣了。安吉拉走进来，她说，查尔斯，我收到了你关于费用报销单的备忘录。谢谢你。史蒂夫当时就想，如果差不多在安吉拉的心里，
Like he sees her, right? Yeah. He understands how much these expense reports have meant to her over the years and how Michael just never cared about them. So he was like, great note. Great note. He was like, Angela, what if this is like personal? So that's why I walked in. I was like, Charles, I got your memo about the expense reports.
这就像是写给她个人的备忘录呢？就像他注意到了她，对吧？是的。他理解这些费用报销单多年来对她有多么重要，而迈克尔却从来不在乎它们。所以他当时说，好建议。真是个好建议。他就像是，安吉拉，如果这像是私人的呢？所以我走了进去，我说，查尔斯，我收到了你关于费用报销单的备忘录。
Thank you. And I sort of touched my chest. Yeah. for seeing me. This starts an amazing runner, Jenna, about the expense reports. The whole entire thing got deleted for time, and I'm going to share about it. Before I play the first one, I want you to know when Angela leaves the room and Dwight says to Charles, been there, done that. That was not in the script. Oh, Rain improvised that. Rain improvised that. And then immediately after the scene would have started this expense reports runner. Angela is delighted to be policing
谢谢你。我还摸了摸胸口。是的，谢谢你注意到我。这就引发了一个精彩的连环桥段，珍娜，关于费用报销单的。整段内容因为时间关系都被删掉了，我会跟大家分享。在我播放第一个片段之前，我想让你们知道，当安吉拉离开房间，德怀特对查尔斯说，这种事我经历过、做过了。那不是剧本里的。哦，雷恩是即兴发挥的。雷恩是即兴发挥的。紧接着那场戏之后，就会开始这个费用报销单的连环桥段。安吉拉很高兴能去整顿
people. Here is clip number one. Stanley. Andrea. Rejected? You never had a problem with me expensive cigars before. Yes, I did. I just didn't have the power to enforce it. Phyllis, this client you take out to offer you as every Saturday night, wouldn't happen to be a refrigeration company, would it? Michael never cared. He said it was a perk of the job.
纪律。这里是第一段剪辑。斯坦利。安吉拉。被拒绝了？你以前从不介意我报销昂贵的雪茄。不，我介意。我只是以前没有权力去执行。菲利斯，你每个星期六晚上带去应酬的这个客户，该不会是一家制冷公司吧？迈克尔从来不在乎。他说这是工作的福利。
Hmm. I'm sorry. I get no joy from this. All right. So on that line, on that line, I get no joy from this. I turn around and I walk away beaming with the biggest smile. And so I took a screen grab of it. It's hilarious. I'm going to put it in stories. And then right after this, there would have been back to back Phyllis and Angela talking heads. And this is what Angela said in her talking head. She holds up a rejected stamp and says, I bought it for myself for my birthday. I've been waiting for a chance to use it. It came with an approve stamp, which I can't seem to find. Amazing. And then Phyllis would have had a talking head immediately after that said, that little bitch, get with the program. A free dinner here,
嗯。我很抱歉。我从中得不到任何快乐。好吧，就在那句台词上，就在那句台词“我从中得不到任何快乐”上，我转过身，带着灿烂的笑容走开了。所以我截了张图。太搞笑了。我要把它发到快拍里。就在这之后，本来会有菲利斯和安吉拉背靠背的独白。这就是安吉拉在独白中所说的。她举起一枚“已拒绝”的印章说，这是我自己买给自己的生日礼物。我一直在等机会用它。它还附带一个“已批准”的印章，但我好像找不到了。太棒了。然后紧接着，菲利斯会有一段独白说，那个小贱人，赶紧跟上节奏。这儿有一顿免费晚餐，
a bottle of wine there. Everybody's happy. You take away my perks. See you later, alligator. Ooh, Phyllis, sass. What is that? See you later alligator. I'm not sure. I don't know if you want to find out. I know. So there was all this hullabaloo with Angela rejecting everyone's expense reports. keeps playing out. I'll share more later. Well, next up, we're going to go down to the Michael Scott Paper Company, where everyone is so tired. Well, they've been getting up at 4.30 in the morning every day. Ryan thinks they should get a delivery guy. Michael thinks they should just maybe build a loft for Pam in particular.
那儿有一瓶酒。大家都高兴。你剥夺了我的福利。回头见，短吻鳄。噢，菲利斯，真尖酸。那是什么？回头见，短吻鳄。我不确定。我不知道你是否想弄明白。我知道。所以安吉拉拒绝所有人的费用报销单，这里面有各种各样的闹剧。剧情还在继续。我稍后会分享更多。好了，接下来，我们要去迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司，那里每个人都累坏了。好吧，他们每天早上4点30分就起床了。瑞安认为他们应该找个送货员。迈克尔认为他们也许应该为帕姆专门建一个阁楼。
Yeah, just bunk up there, Pam. Michael's like, yeah, dorm rooms have lofts. And Ryan's like, no, they don't, Michael. But did you have a loft in your dorm? Because I did. No, I had two twin beds in my dorm. room. My dad built me aloft and I put my bed up high and I put my desk underneath it, just like Michael said. Well, I had friends that had that in their bedrooms growing up, but in my college, you had a roommate.
对，就在那儿搭个铺，帕姆。迈克尔说，对啊，大学宿舍都有阁楼。瑞安说，不，并没有，迈克尔。不过你在宿舍里有阁楼吗？因为我有。不，我的宿舍里有两张单人床。我爸爸给我搭了个阁楼，我把床抬高，把书桌放在下面，就像迈克尔说的那样。嗯，我小时候有朋友的卧室里有那个，但在我的大学里，你得有个室友。
Did you not have a roommate? I did have a roommate. Your dad bit a loft on your side of the, I had a one room, dorm room with two twin beds and a little sink in the corner. Yeah, so we had like a Jack and Jill bathroom situation. Oh, I had to go down the hall. I had a little shower. catty. And I had to walk to a like community shower. I mean, it was a girl's dorm. But, you know. I'm not going to lie. I kind of picked my college because of the bathroom. Because of the dorm room situation, like slightly. I loved my school. I went to Truman State in rural Missouri. It was amazing. I loved it there. But the dorms at the time, this was a little rare. You had like two bedrooms separated by a bathroom. So it would be four girls sharing one bathroom. But guess what? What? The dorm room on the other
难道你没有室友吗？我确实有个室友。你爸爸在你那一侧搭了个阁楼，我当时住的是单间宿舍，里面有两张单人床和一个角落里的小水槽。对，所以我们有点像杰克和吉尔式的浴室布局。哦，我得去走廊。我有一个小淋浴间。公共盥洗室。我得走到一个类似公共浴室的地方。我的意思是，那是个女生宿舍。但是，你知道的。我不会撒谎。我选这所大学多多少少是因为它的浴室。因为宿舍的情况，稍微有一点。我爱我的学校。我去了密苏里州乡村的杜鲁门州立大学。太棒了。我很喜欢那里。但当时的宿舍，这有点罕见。你有两个由浴室隔开的卧室。所以会是四个女生共用一个浴室。不过你猜怎么着？什么？我们浴室另一边的
side of our bathroom had an issue. It was like really smelly. Like maybe it smelled like maybe an animal died in the wall. Ew, gross. It was so gross. So they didn't put anyone in there. So we were just two girls with one bathroom. So it was only two of us, you know, me and my roommate shared. And at first, my roommate and I were like, what if we open the window and air it out? We could just make that like a living room. We were all excited. Okay, we tried. We could not get rid of that smell. Did you report it? Yeah. And they could never get rid of the smell. It just stayed empty. Luckily, if you kept the bathroom door shut to that room, it didn't come our way. Yeah. I don't know what happened in there, but as a result, we got a pretty private bathroom. That's amazing.
宿舍出了点问题。里面味道很重。就像闻起来像是有什么动物死在墙里了一样。噢，太恶心了。太恶心了。所以他们没有安排任何人住进去。因此我们就成了两个女生共用一个浴室。所以只有我们两个人，你知道的，我和我室友共用。起初，我和室友在想，如果我们把窗户打开通通风会怎么样？我们可以把它当成客厅。我们都很兴奋。好吧，我们试过了。我们没法除掉那个味道。你们报告了吗？报告了。但他们始终除不掉那个味道。它就一直空着。幸运的是，如果你把通往那个房间的浴室门关上，味道就飘不到我们这边。是的。我不知道那里发生了什么，但结果是，我们得到了一个相当私密的浴室。太棒了。
Yeah. I went to Baylor University. I loved my dorm room, Collins, my Collins girls out there, but I shared one room. We had the shower down the hall. And my roommate's name was also Angela. Oh. So everyone in college called me Kinsey. And I still to this day know anyone who knew me in college because all my messages like on voicemail, like my husband can always tell because they're like, Kinsey, what's up? No one knew my name was Angela. I think a lot of people just thought my name was Kinsey. My roommate, I loved her. Her name was T.J. And she came from such a small town in Iowa that you could just write her name. And then the city and state and zip code, you did not have to write her house number or her street. That's my hometown, Jenna. And she would get mail. I found that so cool that I would write her letters on break. And then we'd come back and be like, did you get it? She'd be like, oh, yeah. And I went home with her once to like, you know, visit. And it was amazing. like she was the coolest. That was my hometown. I mean, we didn't have to dial a full phone number,
是的。我去了贝勒大学。我很喜欢我的宿舍，柯林斯宿舍，柯林斯的女孩们，但我共用一个房间。我们的淋浴间在走廊尽头。我室友的名字也叫安吉拉。哦。所以大学里的每个人都叫我金西。直到今天，我还能认出任何一个在大学里认识我的人，因为我所有的留言信箱，比如我丈夫总是能分辨出来，因为他们会说，金西，最近怎么样？没有人知道我的名字叫安吉拉。我觉得很多人都以为我的名字叫金西。我的室友，我非常喜欢她。她的名字叫T.J.。她来自爱荷华州的一个小镇，你只要写下她的名字，然后写上城市、州和邮政编码，你甚至都不用写她的门牌号或街道。那是我的家乡，珍娜。她会收到信。我觉得这太酷了，以至于我在假期里会给她写信。然后我们回来后就会问，你收到了吗？她会说，哦，对。我曾跟她回家去过一次，你知道的，去拜访。这太棒了。就像她是那最酷的人。那是我的家乡。我的意思是，我们甚至不需要拨打完整的电话号码，
just four digits, and you could get anyone in town. Wow. I know. Crazy times. But I guess to wrap that up, I'll just say, I had a loft. You had a loft. So Michael had a loft. So Michael had a point. He did. I want to point out in this scene at three minutes, 55 seconds. You can see the latest fish in the fish. It's an all-black gold fish. This is going to be the last fish of Michael Scott Paper Company. Yeah, why didn't Michael bring the fish to his office? I don't know. That's a really good point, Angela. What happened to me? Well, Randy told us in real life, this fish went to his assistant Jackie, and it lived on her desk for two years. He said the fish kept getting bigger and bigger and bigger, and they had to get bigger fish bowls to accommodate it.
只要四位数字，你就能联系到镇上的任何人。哇。我知道。疯狂的时光。不过我想总结一下，我曾有过阁楼。你曾有过阁楼。所以迈克尔也有个阁楼。所以迈克尔有他的道理。他确实有。我想指出在这场戏的3分55秒处。你能看到鱼缸里的最新那条鱼。那是一条全黑的金鱼。这将是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的最后一条鱼。是的，为什么迈克尔不把鱼带到他的办公室去呢？我不知道。这真是一个好问题，安吉拉。我怎么了？好吧，兰迪在现实生活中告诉我们，这条鱼被送给了他的助理杰姬，并在她的办公桌上活了两年。他说这条鱼变得越来越大，他们不得不换更大的鱼缸来容纳它。
But she took very, very good care of it. Well, I have appreciated your documentation of the fish every week. I feel like it was your plant. It was my plant at reception. It was. Well, it's over. That's your last fish breakdown. Okay.
但她把它照顾得非常好。嗯，我很感激你每周对这条鱼的记录。我觉得它就像是你的植物。它在接待处是我的植物。确实是。好吧，这一切都结束了。这是你最后一次剖析鱼了。好吧。
Back upstairs on Dundermifflin, special guests coming in, David Wallace, to check in on things because they keep losing clients. And Charles seems very enamored with David Wallace. Once to impress him. Yeah. We had a fan catch in this, which delighted me. Okay. Many people wrote in to say, does. Is Idriselba break character at 5 minutes 25 seconds when Kevin says hi to David Wallace?
回到丹德米夫林的楼上，有特别嘉宾到来，大卫·华莱士来视察情况，因为他们不断失去客户。查尔斯似乎非常迷恋大卫·华莱士。想要给他留下好印象。是的。我们在这一集中遇到了一个粉丝发现的细节，这让我很高兴。好吧。许多人写信问，伊德里斯·艾尔巴在5分25秒时，当凯文向大卫·华莱士打招呼时，是不是出戏了？
I totally saw that too, and he does. He does. He does. Totally. I wondered if that was like an addition because everyone, you know, David is trying to get things going, but people keep interrupting just to say hi. Yeah. And Kevin has this late breaking hello.
我完全也看到了，他确实出戏了。他确实。他确实。完全是的。我想知道这是否像是一个附加动作，因为每个人，你知道的，大卫正试图让事情运转起来，但大家总是打断他，只为了打个招呼。是的。而凯文有一个姗姗来迟的问候。
Very funny. Idris totally broke character. A hundred percent. If you want to see just a glimmer of the charming man that Idraselba is, you can see it at five minutes, 24 seconds, because he gets a little smiley twinkle in his eye. After Charles greets David Wallace, Jim just watches this whole thing play out. And then there is a cutaway to him in the break room, and he's just doing kissy noises. Right? Well, that was not in the script.
太搞笑了。伊德里斯完全出戏了。百分之百。如果你想看一眼伊德里斯·艾尔巴迷人的一面，你可以在5分24秒时看到，因为他的眼里闪过一丝微笑的亮光。在查尔斯迎接大卫·华莱士之后，吉姆只是看着这一切发生。然后镜头切到了休息室里的他，他正在发出亲亲的声音。对吧？嗯，这并不在剧本里。
That must have happened on the day. In the script, it's a talking head. and this was Jim's scripted line. So, oh, M.G. Turns out Charles Minor is a huge kiss ass. Mmm. But I kind of liked that it was just the kissing noise. I did too.
那肯定是在拍摄当天发生的。在剧本里，这是一个单人访谈镜头，而这是吉姆剧本里的台词。所以，哦，天哪。原来查尔斯·迈纳是个彻头彻尾的马屁精。嗯。但我有点喜欢仅仅是亲吻声音的处理。我也喜欢。
Right? He just was like, we know what's happening here. Well, David is telling everyone that although Michael Scott Paper Company has stolen some clients, he believes it's just a temporary setback. But this brings on some real Phyllis sass. Yeah. She's like, perhaps if you had returned Michael's phone calls, this would have never happened. What you need to know about Phyllis is that she's already pissed off because of the expense reports. So she is not mincing her words. And then David is going to invite Jim to join him and Charles in the conference room.
对吧？他当时就像是，我们都知道这里在发生什么。好吧，大卫在告诉大家，尽管迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司已经抢走了一些客户，但他相信这只是暂时的挫折。但这引发了菲利斯的一些真正的讽刺。是的。她说，也许如果你回了迈克尔的电话，这一切就永远不会发生了。你需要了解菲利斯的是，她因为费用报表的事已经很不高兴了。所以她说话毫不留情。然后大卫邀请吉姆和他以及查尔斯一起去会议室。
And Charles is like, hold up, Dwight's been my guy. Jim, not living up to his potential. And David's like, I'm, surprised by that. Oh my gosh. It's so amazing. So good. And it plays out so well because David says, let's invite them both. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. I think we should take a break because when we come back, I mean, there's some serious accounting issues over at Michael Scott Paper Company. Oh my gosh. It made me laugh out loud. All right. We will take a break. We'll be back. Well, we are back, and the Michael Scott Paper company has decided to go speak to an accountant to see if they can hire a delivery guy. But they can't. Not only can they not afford a delivery guy, they are bleeding money. Their prices are putting them out of business. It's not looking good for Michael's got paper
查尔斯却说，等等，德怀特一直是我的手下。吉姆没有发挥出他的潜力。大卫说，我很惊讶。哦，天哪。太棒了。太棒了。而且效果非常好，因为大卫说，我们邀请他们两个吧。嗯嗯。嗯嗯。我想我们该休息一下了，因为当我们回来时，我是说，迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司那边有一些严重的财务问题。哦，天哪。这让我大声笑出来。好的。我们要休息一下。我们马上回来。好吧，我们回来了，迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司决定去找一个会计，看看他们能不能雇一个送货员。但他们不能。他们不仅雇不起送货员，而且还在流血亏损。他们的定价让他们面临倒闭。迈克尔·斯科特纸业的情况不容乐观
company. It's not. It's also not looking great for Ryan because he had calculated all this. Yes, but he used a fixed cost formula and he should have used a variable cost formula. Mm-hmm. He seems a little confused by those terms. Yeah. I looked it up. I wrote up a whole thing about it and I still don't understand it. So, oh my gosh. I mean, I think if I think really, really hard, I can get there. Okay. Are we going to have to think hard right now? I don't know. I mean, I can just skip it. Do we want to think hard or no? Well, let's give it a try. All right. All right, everybody. Ready? Variable and fixed costs are the two main types of costs that a company incurs. Okay. Variable costs are volume-related.
确实不容乐观。瑞安的情况也很不妙，因为他计算了所有这些。是的，但他用的是固定成本公式，而他本应该用变动成本公式。嗯嗯。他对这些术语似乎有点困惑。是的。我查过了。我写了整整一篇关于它的文章，但我还是不理解。所以，哦，天哪。我是说，如果我非常非常努力地去想，我大概能弄明白。好吧。我们现在必须绞尽脑汁吗？我不知道。我是说，我可以跳过它。我们想费脑子想想，还是不呢？好吧，我们试试看。好吧。好吧，各位。准备好了吗？变动成本和固定成本是公司产生的两类主要成本。好吧。变动成本与产量有关。
Okay. They vary with the amount of products you're making. Okay. While fixed costs are time-related, they stay consistent. It doesn't matter how much stuff you make just to keep the lights on, these are your fixed costs. So, for example, your rent on your office space, that isn't going to change month to month. If you make five widgets or 500 widgets, your rent is the same. Right.
好吧。它们随着你生产的产品的数量而变化。好吧。而固定成本与时间有关，它们保持一致。不管你生产多少东西，仅仅为了维持运转，这些就是你的固定成本。所以，举个例子，你的办公室租金，月复一月是不会变的。无论你生产5个小物件还是500个小物件，你的租金都是一样的。对。
But what if you have an employee that gets injured? And now you have to file workman's comp, and you're paying all this extra stuff. Well, that would go under your variable costs. I'm with you. Oh, my gosh, our brains are working. We're doing it. So the more fixed costs you have, the more revenue your company needs in order to break even. So that makes sense. The more overhead you have, the more you have to make.
但是如果你有一个员工受伤了呢？现在你必须申请工伤赔偿，你得支付所有这些额外的费用。好吧，那就会归入你的变动成本。我懂了。哦，天哪，我们的大脑在运转。我们做到了。所以你的固定成本越多，你的公司需要的收入就越多才能达到收支平衡。所以这讲得通。你的间接费用越多，你必须赚得就越多。
I mean, Ryan went to business school. He was the vice president of the Northeast region or whatever. I know. Now, if you produce 500 widgets, that's going to really offset your fixed cost, right? Okay. But if you produce your 500 widgets for not enough money, you're never going to cover your fixed costs. Got it. And then your variable costs are going to put you out of business as well. I don't know. I think we got it.
我是说，瑞安上过商学院。他是东北地区的副总裁什么的。我知道。现在，如果你生产500个小物件，那将真正抵消你的固定成本，对吧？好吧。但如果你生产这500个小物件的售价不够高，你就永远无法弥补你的固定成本。明白了。然后你的变动成本也会让你破产。我不知道。我想我们搞懂了。
Kind of. The point is they cannot afford a delivery driver. Ryan's accounting was horrible, and they are going out of business because their prices are too low. Yes. And all of this information was delivered by a delightful. guest star playing the accountant Ty Platt, and that person is Kurt Scholar. He is a seasoned improvisational performer. He's done a ton of television. Angela, I believe you knew him from your improv days. I did. Kurt and I were both at iOS. He is so smart and quick and funny. Really talented guy.
算是吧。关键是他们雇不起送货司机。瑞安的会计做得很糟糕，他们要破产了，因为他们的价格定得太低了。是的。所有这些信息都是由一位扮演会计泰·普拉特的可爱客串演员传达的，那个人是库尔特·斯考勒。他是一位经验丰富的即兴表演者。他演过大量的电视节目。安吉拉，我相信你从你即兴表演的时期就认识他。我是认识。库尔特和我都曾在iOS。他非常聪明、敏捷又有趣。真的是个很有才华的人。
Again, we were so lucky to get such great guest stars on our show. Well, you know, on his computer, when Michael is like crunch those numbers again. Yeah. And he hits a number and nothing changes. Well, nothing could ever change because that was a faky spreadsheet on the computer. It was made by our graphics designer Michael Marcus. You know, I said earlier that Michael also made the decal for the side of the van. Yeah.
再说一次，我们能在节目中请到这么棒的客串演员真是太幸运了。好吧，你知道的，在他的电脑上，当迈克尔说“重新计算一下那些数字”时。是的。他按了一个数字，但没有任何改变。好吧，什么都不会改变，因为那是电脑上的一个假电子表格。那是我们的平面设计师迈克尔·马库斯制作的。你知道的，我之前说过，迈克尔还制作了面包车车身上的贴花。是的。
And it just got me thinking, if you are a graphics designer, you can work for a TV show. TV shows have a graphics designer on their team. Yeah. That's so cool. I know. He would make logos and all kinds of things for us when we needed faky signs and props and things. We needed things like that almost weekly. Yes.
这让我想到，如果你是一名平面设计师，你可以为电视节目工作。电视节目他们的团队里都有一名平面设计师。是的。太酷了。我知道。当我们需要假的标志、道具和类似的东西时，他会为我们制作标志和各种东西。我们几乎每周都需要这样的东西。是的。
So he would work with Phil Shea to design these things and with Michael Gallenberg, our production designer. I have to share with you guys after this scene, Ryan was going to have a complete meltdown. It's in the deleted scenes. It is so crazy. but it's like Ryan is faced with the fact that, A, this new business that he was, I guess, optimistic about is going out of business, but also the fact that he crunched the numbers and he was wrong. And he is actually not very good at being a businessman. And he loses it, Jenna. It's in the deleted scenes on the DVD. He throws those cheese balls. He opens it up and he just starts throwing them everywhere. I am talking everywhere. He dumps the entire content. painer and is yelling, and Michael's just watching it all happen. Is Pam there? Pam leaves.
所以他会与菲尔·谢伊合作设计这些东西，还会与我们的制作设计师迈克尔·盖伦伯格合作。我必须跟你们分享的是，在这场戏之后，瑞安将会彻底崩溃。这在被删减的片段里。太疯狂了。但这就好像瑞安面临着这样的事实：A，这个他曾抱有乐观态度的这项新业务正在倒闭，还有他计算了数字却算错了的事实。而且他实际上并不擅长做一个商人。他崩溃了，珍娜。这在DVD的被删减片段里。他扔了那些奶酪球。他把它打开，然后开始到处乱扔。我是说到处都是。他把容器里的东西全倒了，还在大喊大叫，而迈克尔只是看着这一切发生。帕姆在那儿吗？帕姆走了。
When he starts throwing things, she leaves. I don't remember this. Yeah. Isn't that crazy? Yes. I totally get why this one didn't make it in because it was kind of over the top. Like Ryan trashes their office. Well, what actually made it in the episode is that they just returned.
当他开始扔东西时，她就走了。我不记得这个了。真的吗？是不是很疯狂？是的。我完全明白为什么这一段没有放进正片里，因为它有点太夸张了。就像瑞安把他们的办公室砸了个稀巴烂。好吧，真正进入正片的是他们只是回去了。
They're very just down in the dumps. And Michael starts calling clients and saying, you know what, actually, we need you to give us more money. Could you imagine? No. Could you imagine if you bought something from a company and then they called you later in the day and said, will you pay me more for that? Because I'm actually going out of business. Yeah.
他们简直沮丧极了。然后迈克尔开始给客户打电话说，你知道吗，实际上，我们需要你们给我们更多钱。你能想象吗？不。你能想象如果你从一家公司买东西，然后他们那天晚些时候打电话给你说，你能为这个付我更多钱吗？因为我实际上快要倒闭了。对。
That is such a weird phone call. I know. And Pam has that great talking head. She does. She says, when a child gets behind the wheel of a car and crashes into a tree, you don't blame the kid. You blame the 30-year-old woman in the passenger seat who trusted the kid and said, go ahead, drive, kid. Yeah, you've got... Something like that, I'm paraphrasing.
那真是个奇怪的电话。我知道。帕姆有一个很棒的面对镜头独白。她确实有。她说，当一个孩子坐上汽车方向盘撞上一棵树时，你不会责怪这个孩子。你会责怪副驾驶座上信任这个孩子并说，去吧，开吧，孩子的那个30岁女人。是的，你懂的……差不多是这样，我是意译的。
Yeah. It's pretty great. You got this. You got this, kid. Yeah. Lady, should we go back up to the conference room for a scene that I couldn't get enough of? I enjoyed the scene so much. You guys know that Jen and I watched these episodes two to four times before we record.
对。挺棒的。你行的。你行的，孩子。对。女士们，我们应该回会议室看那个让我看不够的场景吗？我很喜欢这个场景。你们知道詹和我录制前会把这些剧集看两到四遍。
This was a highlight every single time. One of my absolute favorite moments in the entire episode is when Dwight suggests, you know, getting all of his bees and putting the bees in the the office, watch Idris as Charles turn and just look at Dwight as he's giving his B speech. Everything going across Idris's face of like, holy crap. Who have I attached myself to in front of David Wallace? I also love the attention to detail in the scene visually. I don't know if you noticed, but Jim and David Wallace are both wearing blue shirts. with kind of blue ties. And on the other side of the table,
每一次这都是亮点。整集中我绝对最喜欢的时刻之一，是德怀特建议，你知道，弄来他所有的蜜蜂，把蜜蜂放在办公室里，看着伊德里斯饰演的查尔斯转身，在德怀特发表他的蜜蜂演讲时看着他。伊德里斯脸上的各种表情仿佛在说，天哪。我在大卫·华莱士面前把自己跟什么人绑在了一起？我也很喜欢这个场景在视觉上的细节处理。我不知道你们有没有注意到，吉姆和大卫·华莱士都穿着蓝衬衫，配着那种蓝领带。而在桌子的另一边，
Dwight and Charles both have on kind of like a white or a light yellow, canary yellow. Yeah. Brilliant. Yeah. So cool. It's almost like teams.
德怀特和查尔斯都穿着那种白色或浅黄色、金丝雀黄的衣服。对。太棒了。对。太酷了。简直就像是分队。
They have on their team colors. Yes. Also, I noticed in the scene at 8 minutes, 56 seconds, a Fiji water bottle. I saw that too. And I thought. Once again, with the label turned away from camera. I was like,
他们穿着各自的队服。是的。另外，我注意到在8分56秒的场景中，有一个斐济水瓶。我也看到了。我当时想。又是标签背对镜头。我当时就想，
What is this? What is that? Because it showed up back in Wallace's office. He had a water bottle. Remember my son did the whole water bottle break down? Yeah, yeah. Fancy water bottle for David Wallace. I'm going to ask Randy about it.
这是什么？那是什么？因为它又出现在华莱士的办公室里。他有一个水瓶。还记得我儿子做的那个水瓶全解析吗？对，对。大卫·华莱士的高级水瓶。我要去问问兰迪。
Yeah. Why the Fiji water showing up in scenes all the time? Were they given us money? No, the label is not facing camera. I know, but everybody knows it's Fiji because they're the square bottle. I'm going to get to the bottom of it. Get to the bottom of it. We haven't seen a lot of Jim and Pam together in this episode.
对。为什么斐济水总是在场景里出现？他们给我们钱了吗？不对，标签没有面向镜头。我知道，但大家都知道那是斐济，因为它们是方瓶子。我要查个水落石出。查个水落石出。在这集里我们没怎么看到吉姆和帕姆在一起。
Or in any of these episodes. I know. Yeah. Well, they're working at rival paper companies. I guess so. They do have this great scene in the hallway where Pam tells Jim that they have about a month before they're going to go out of business. And he tells her not to worry, but then his phone starts ringing. Yes, I have an audio clip of it.
或者在这些剧集里都没怎么看到。我知道。对。好吧，他们在竞争对手的纸业公司工作。我想也是。他们在走廊里有一个很棒的场景，帕姆告诉吉姆，他们大概还有一个月就要倒闭了。他告诉她不用担心，但接着他的电话开始响了。是的，我有一段音频剪辑。
Idiot. Idiot. Idiot. That's Jim's ringtone. Yes. Now, to create the rink tone, they record. recorded Rain saying idiot. Right. And then our post-production supervisor, Jake Gost, put it on a loop. And then our sound engineer actually put a speaker on the set next to us. It was not actually coming from the phone. In post-production, they put a filter on the sound to make it sound like it was coming from the phone. But that was like a whole faky ringtone thing we had to set up. So nowadays, obviously, you can get customize ringtones for your phones. And you can actually get this ringtone over on office tally.com. No way.
白痴。白痴。白痴。那是吉姆的手机铃声。是的。为了制作这个铃声，他们录制了。录下了雷恩说“白痴”。对。然后我们的后期制作主管杰克·戈斯特把它做成了循环播放。然后我们的音响工程师实际上在我们旁边的片场放了一个扬声器。声音其实不是从电话里传出来的。在后期制作中，他们在声音上加了一个滤镜，让它听起来像是从电话里传出来的。但这就像是我们必须设置的一个假铃声。所以现在，很明显，你可以为手机获取自定义铃声。你实际上可以在officetally.com上找到这个铃声。不会吧。
Yeah. I love that. Well, when I watched this moment, I started laughing so hard because I remembered years later into the show, Kenneth Paul, who did my makeup, who also did Rain Wilson's makeup, had Rain do like a voice memo, and he made that his ringtone. So Kenneth Paul's ringtone, was Rain Wilson doing? this. Ring! Ring! Ring! It was so annoying. And whenever KPs' phone would ring, I'd be like, oh my God, Kenneth Paul. Have you ever had a personalized ringtone? I haven't. Me either.
对。我太喜欢了。好吧，当我看到这一幕时，我笑得前仰后合，因为我记起多年后在这部剧里，为我化妆的肯尼斯·保罗，他同时也给雷恩·威尔逊化妆，让雷恩录了一个语音备忘录，他把那个做成了他的手机铃声。所以肯尼斯·保罗的铃声，是雷恩·威尔逊在学这个。铃！铃！铃！太烦人了。每当KP的手机响时，我都想，天哪，肯尼斯·保罗。你用过个性化铃声吗？我没有。我也没有。
Maybe we should. Should we make it the Office Ladies theme as our ringtone, or is that too narcissistic? Maybe. I was going to just have Keanu Reeves maybe be my ringtone. Like, you know what? What if... I'm fainting with excitement over this idea. What if my ringtone is just surfs up, bra? What if that? Or my ringtone could be, I know kung fu.
也许我们应该。我们应该把《办公室女士》的主题曲当作铃声吗，还是说这太自恋了？也许吧。我本来只想用基努·里维斯当我的铃声。就像，你知道吗？如果……我因这个想法而兴奋得快要晕倒了。如果我的铃声只是“冲浪兴隆，老兄”呢？如果那样呢？或者我的铃声可以是，“我懂功夫”。
All I know for certain is that when we're finished recording today, I will be looking up Keanu ringtones. Yes. This I know for sure. Okay, where are we? We are back down in Michael Scott Paper Company, and Michael is on the floor. They're so mopey. They're so mopey.
我唯一能确定的是，当我们今天录制结束时，我会去查查基努的铃声。是的。这是我能确定的。好了，我们到哪儿了？我们回到了迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司，迈克尔倒在地上了。他们太消沉了。他们太消沉了。
Michael says he always thought that the day Steve Martin died would be the worst day of his life, but he was wrong because it's this. Pam's like, you know Steve Martin's not dead. And he's like, I know, I have to say something. Yeah. Have you watched Steve Martin's new show on Hulu only murders in the building? I haven't. And so many people are telling me to watch it. I know you love it.
迈克尔说他一直以为史蒂夫·马丁去世的那天会是他生命中最糟糕的一天，但他猜错了，因为今天是。帕姆说，你知道史蒂夫·马丁没死。而他说，我知道，我得说点什么。对。你看过史蒂夫·马丁在Hulu上的新剧《大楼里只有谋杀》吗？我没看。有好多人让我去看。我知道你很喜欢。
Okay. Absolutely loved it. Amy Ryan is on it. She even talked about it on our podcast. Yes. She's so good. You know, the premise of the show is that this guy in their building named Tim Kono has been murdered and these three residents come together to try to solve the crime while doing a podcast about it. In episode two of only murders in the building, this show that Steve Martin is in that he created, I want you to hear what they say. Okay. What if Tim was a dick? That's a definite angle.
好的。绝对大爱。艾米·瑞安参演了。她甚至在我们的播客里谈过这部剧。是的。她演得太好了。你知道的，这部剧的设定是，他们大楼里的一个名叫蒂姆·科诺的家伙被谋杀了，这三个居民聚在一起试图破案，同时还做了一个关于此案的播客。在《大楼里只有谋杀》第二集里，也就是史蒂夫·马丁参演并创作的这部剧，我想让你们听听他们说了什么。好吧。如果蒂姆是个混蛋呢？这绝对是个切入点。
I mean, I wouldn't want them to be dickier than Steve Carell in the office. I'd still care if Steve Carell in the office got murdered, or would I? Thinking, thinking, visualizing the system. We need to find someone who knew them. How about that for full circle? Yeah. Pretty amazing. So Steve Carell references Steve Martin, and then on Steve Martin show, they reference Steve
我的意思是，我可不希望他们比《办公室》里的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔更混蛋。如果《办公室》里的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔被谋杀了，我还是会在乎的，或者我会吗？思考中，思考中，脑补这个体系。我们需要找一个认识他们的人。这样算不算首尾呼应？对。太神奇了。所以史蒂夫·卡瑞尔提到了史蒂夫·马丁，然后在史蒂夫·马丁的剧里，他们提到了史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。
Corell. Yes. I'm okay. I think we need to discuss. There's some big revelations that happen in the scene. I was going to say, Pam says that she's applied for a job at Target, Old Navy, and Walmart, and none of them even called her in for an interview. Ryan confesses that he didn't even go to Thailand.
卡瑞尔。是的。我没事。我觉得我们需要讨论一下。这个场景中发生了一些重大的爆料。我正要说，帕姆说她申请了塔吉特、老海军和沃尔玛的工作，但他们甚至没有打电话叫她去面试。瑞安承认他根本没去过泰国。
No, just Fort Lauderdale. That is so perfect. I thought that was so brilliant. Of course Ryan lied about going to Thailand. Of course. And this is when Michael pretends that he loves Pad Thai, because Ryan said there was a great Pad Thai place in Fort Lauderdale. But then Ryan's like, you've never had pad tie. Michael's like, I haven't done a lot of things.
没有，只是劳德代尔堡。太完美了。我觉得这太绝了。瑞安当然撒谎说去了泰国。当然。这就是迈克尔假装他喜欢泰式炒河粉的时候，因为瑞安说劳德代尔堡有一家很棒的泰式炒河粉店。但接着瑞安说，你从来没吃过泰式炒河粉。迈克尔说，我有很多事都没做过。
This was a fan catch by Ella W and Abby W. What'd you catch? What'd you catch? They said in Diversity Day, Michael wishes aloud that he had some pad tie because he loves pad tie. Oh my gosh. Mm-hmm. Great catch. So they wondered, has Michael been telling people that he loves pad tie for years and he's still never tried it?
这是粉丝艾拉·W和艾比·W发现的细节。你们发现了什么？你们发现了什么？他们说在《多元化日》里，迈克尔大声许愿说他希望能有一些泰式炒河粉，因为他超爱泰式炒河粉。哦天哪。嗯哼。发现得太棒了。所以他们在想，难道迈克尔多年来一直告诉别人他爱吃泰式炒河粉，而他却从来没尝过？
That's also, it's also believable that he thinks that maybe it makes him seem well-traveled or something. Yeah. Right? Jenna, after the scene, the expense report deleted runner would have continued. Andy is determined to get an extension on his expense reports and goes to talk to Angela. These expenses are legitimate. Which I denied. Right.
这也是，这也说得通，他觉得这也许能让他显得见多识广什么的。对吧？詹娜，在这场戏之后，原本被删掉的关于报销单的支线剧情本来会继续。安迪决心在报销单上获得宽限，于是去找安吉拉。这些费用都是合法的。我拒绝了。没错。
Would you please respectfully reconsider these? Why would I do that? Because of our history, both romantic and thrace sexual. Twice? Resubmit with proof of business. Names of who you were with, what you talked about, phone numbers I can call to verify. You get a two-hour extension based on our history. Righto.
你能恭敬地重新考虑一下吗？我为什么要这么做？因为我们的过往，既有浪漫的，也有肉欲的。两次？重新提交业务证明。和你在一起的人的名字，你们谈论过的内容，我可以打电话核实的电话号码。根据我们的过往，你获得两个小时的宽限。好吧。
Then we're even. Yeah. Wow. I know. Oh, scandalous. Scandless exchange. So yes, Angela's going to give Andy a two-hour extension. What is he going to do with that? You'll see. Okay. Oh, I'm so glad. I have the clip. I'm glad that pays off. Oh, I'm very sad this runner was deleted. I know. It was really fun. Now we're going to find out that Dunder Mifflin is going to offer Michael Scott Paper Company a buyout.
那我们两清了。是的。哇。我知道。哦，太丑闻了。丑闻般的对话。所以是的，安吉拉要给安迪两个小时的宽限。他要用它做什么？你们会看到的。好的。哦，我太高兴了。我有这段剪辑。我很高兴这个支线有了回报。哦，这个支线被删了，我太难过了。我知道。真的很有趣。现在我们要发现邓德米弗林要向迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司提出收购了。
Yes. So Jim is going to go into Michael's got paper company and give them this news. And Michael is like, what? Why would they want to do that? We're totally like broke. And Jim's like, like, like, like don't, once I hear it, I can't unhear it. So don't say it. And so Michael gets it. Steve has another one of those amazing moments where he comes to a realization very slowly. The three of them are going to go upstairs now to meet. And Ryan and Pam, are like, Michael, you cannot say that we are broke. You cannot do it. Are we clear? We are not going to mention that we are broke. And he's like, I got it. I got it. They get in the elevator. The doors open on the next floor. And he's like, I don't got it. I don't know. I can't do it. I loved it so much. It made me laugh out loud. That's a whole fakey elevator, as everyone knows. We got in the elevator, the guy with the pullies, pulled the rope, shut the doors. And then we relocated to a completely different building. to the Dundermifflin elevator,
是的。所以吉姆要走进迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司并带去这个消息。迈克尔就说，什么？他们为什么想这么做？我们简直穷光蛋了。吉姆就说，别，一旦我听到了，就忘不掉了。所以别说。于是迈克尔懂了。史蒂夫又有了那种精彩的时刻，他非常缓慢地意识到这一点。他们三个现在要上楼去开会了。而瑞安和帕姆则说，迈克尔，你绝对不能说我们破产了。你绝对不能说。听清楚了吗？我们绝不能提我们破产了。他说，我懂了。我懂了。他们进了电梯。门在下一层打开了。他又说，我不懂了。我不知道。我做不到。我太喜欢了。这逗得我哈哈大笑。正如大家所知，那整个电梯都是假的。我们进了电梯，那个拉滑轮的家伙，拉了绳子，关上门。然后我们搬到了一个完全不同的建筑里，来到了邓德米弗林的电梯，
and we got out, and it is seamless. It looks so good. Oh, that was funny. And then we walk in, and Michael has his line that I have seen quoted so many times where he says, well, well, well, how the turntables. Okay, I had to know how that was scripted.
然后我们走了出去，天衣无缝。看起来太棒了。哦，太搞笑了。然后我们走进去，迈克尔说出了那句我看到过无数次被引用的台词，他说，好啦，好啦，好啦，风水轮流转啊。好吧，我当时非得知道这段剧本是怎么写的不可。
So I went to the shooting draft, And that line is not in the script. Oh my gosh. We got a fan question about that. Yeah. I don't know if it was pitched on the fly. You know how sometimes writers would have some pitches or if Steve improvised it. I don't know.
所以我去翻了拍摄剧本，那句台词根本不在剧本里。哦天哪。我们收到了一个关于这个的粉丝提问。是的。我不知道这是不是现场即兴发挥的。你知道有时候编剧会有些即兴点子，或者是不是史蒂夫即兴发挥的。我不知道。
But in the script, this is what it said. Well, well, well. Oh, how the meteors fallen. Hmm. And I love the turntables so much better. Turntables is so funny. I know. Because Michael gets all of his phrases like.
但在剧本里，它是这么写的。好吧，好啦，好啦。哦，流星是怎么陨落的。嗯。我还是更喜欢“风水轮流转”。“风水轮流转”太搞笑了。我知道。因为迈克尔总是把他的成语弄得乱七八糟。
off. And Michael, you know what? I can relate to that. And you still sell... Frider Day. Friday day. For years, I've been saying Friday day. I've been saying lots of things. I love that when they get into the conference room, Michael immediately rejects their first offer. And he says, just give me your second offer. Yeah. And their second offer is a buyout of $12,000. Kelly and Angela are trying to eavesdrop. And Kelly has her ear to the door with like a coffee mug. Mindy and I kept laughing. That was so funny. It was so ridiculous. We're so invested in what Charles is doing. We have to be eavesdropping. And you know, I remember Mindy tried a few different things. In the script, I asked Kelly, what do you hear? And she actually responds and says
出错。迈克尔，你知道吗？我能感同身受。你还在卖……“星期日（Friday day）”。“星期日”。多年来，我一直说“星期日”。我一直在说各种错话。我太喜欢他们走进会议室时，迈克尔立刻拒绝了他们的第一份报价。他说，直接给我你们的第二份报价吧。对。他们的第二份报价是12,000美元的收购费。凯利和安吉拉试图偷听。凯利把耳朵贴在门上，还拿着一个咖啡杯。敏迪和我一直在笑。太搞笑了。太荒谬了。我们太投入于查尔斯在做什么了。我们必须偷听。而且你知道，我记得敏迪尝试了几种不同的方式。在剧本里，我问凯利，你听到什么了？她实际上回答说
the ocean. Oh. But in the episode, we have this, wah-w-w-w-w-want-wwaw-waw-wwww. She was so good at it. She was doing Charlie Brown's teacher, right? It was so funny. We were tickled. Well, Michael is going to reject this offer of $12,000. And this is when he is a brilliant negotiator. I could not believe it. Do you see the look on Pam's face?
是大海。哦。但在正片里，我们有这个，哇-w-w-w-w-想-wwaw-waw-wwww。她演得太好了。她在模仿查理·布朗的老师，对吧？太搞笑了。我们被逗乐了。好吧，迈克尔要拒绝这12,000美元的报价。这就是他展现天才谈判专家的时候了。我简直不敢相信。你看到帕姆脸上的表情了吗？
I do. Pam is all of us in this moment. Exactly. So he gets David to give them an offer of $60,000. Yes, he's like, listen, here's how I see it. You're up for approval by the board. And they're probably not going to be too happy that you are losing customers to Michael Scott Paper Company.
看到了。此刻的帕姆就是我们所有人的缩写。没错。所以他让大卫给他们开出了60,000美元的报价。是的，他说，听着，我是这么看的。你正在等待董事会的批准。他们可能不会太高兴你把客户丢给了迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。
So you actually need me. Yes. So they say we'll give you a moment to discuss it. And now we're going to have a scene out at Dwight and Jim's desks. But did you notice behind them? No one is in the conference room and the door is open. It's a total continuity catch. Ryan, Michael, and Pam should have been in the background there.
所以你实际上需要我。是的。于是他们说，我们会给你一点时间讨论一下。现在我们要切换到德怀特和吉姆办公桌外的场景。但是你们注意到他们身后了吗？会议室里一个人都没有，而且门是开着的。这绝对是一个穿帮漏网之镜头。瑞安、迈克尔和帕姆本应该出现在那里的背景里，
and they're not. Oh, good catch. Yeah. But Dwight gets this phone call from a client saying that Michael Scott Paper Company called them and asked them for more money and they'd like to come back to Dunder Mifflin. And Dwight's going to run into the kitchen and tattle. He's going to tell Charles, Michael Scott paper company is going broke. And normally Charles would take that information from Dwight and go right into action. But Dwight's been acting so strange to Charles all day. And then Jim capitalizes on that. Yeah, he kind of bates Dwight into bringing out his full weirdo by sort of heckling him about his ability to solve cases. And Charles's like, you're both morons. Don't go anywhere near the conference room. Here's what I need to bring up about this scene on a practical level. Did you notice where
但他们不在。哦，好眼尖。对。但德怀特接到一个客户的电话，说迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司打电话向他们索要更多钱，他们想回到邓德米弗林。德怀特跑进厨房打小报告去了。他要告诉查尔斯，迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司快要倒闭了。通常情况下，查尔斯会接受德怀特的这个情报并立即采取行动。但德怀特今天对查尔斯表现得太诡异了。然后吉姆就利用了这一点。是的，他通过取笑德怀特解决案件的能力，有点像是在激怒德怀特，让他彻底展现出自己怪咖的一面。查尔斯就说，你们俩都是白痴。离会议室远点。关于这个场景，从现实角度我需要提出来的是，你们注意到在哪里了吗？
Charles is standing in this scene? By the counter? Yes. But, very close to the fridge. Yeah. And through the entire scene, he's got his Sattacois steel coffee mug. Yeah. And he's got a full coffee pot. Each hand is holding one of these items. Why did he walk so far away from the coffee maker to put his coffee in his mug?
查尔斯在这个场景里站着吗？在柜台旁？是的。但是，离冰箱非常近。对。而且在整个场景中，他一直拿着他的Sattacois钢制咖啡杯。对。而且他拿了一个满的咖啡壶。两只手各拿其中一样东西。他为什么离咖啡机那么远才把咖啡倒进杯子里？
Because the coffee maker is over by the door that leads to the office. So this man is saddled with these two coffee items. And I'm just like, why did he drift? In my mind, as an actor, I'm having to make up a reason why this happened. So I'm imagining he got the coffee pot and he's starting to pour. And he notices something on the fridge. He wants to get a closer look. And then Dwight comes in and he's now stuck with his two coffees.
因为咖啡机在通往办公室的门那边。所以这个人手里挂着这两样咖啡用品。我当时就在想，他为什么走神了？在我的脑海里，作为一名演员，我必须编造一个这件事发生的原因。所以我脑补的画面是，他拿了咖啡壶，开始倒咖啡。然后他注意到了冰箱上的什么东西。他想仔细看看。接着德怀特进来了，而他现在被这两杯咖啡给绊住了。
I don't know. It was an odd staging for me. And I became distracted. I love that like this moment pulled you out for a minute. Like as an actor process, you're like, that makes no sense. I'm like, I need a reason. I need a motivation. Back in the conference room, Michael says no to this very lucrative offer.
我不知道。对我来说这是一个奇怪的舞台调度。然后我分心了。我喜欢这种时刻，它把你拉出戏好一会儿。就像演员的处理方式一样，你会觉得，这毫无逻辑。我就想，我需要一个理由。我需要一个动机。回到会议室里，迈克尔拒绝了这个非常丰厚的报价。
Yeah, and Pam is like, can we have another minute? Yeah. And this is when Michael, again, makes perfect sense. And he says, what we need are jobs. We don't need a buyout. That money's not going to last forever. We need employment. And everyone agrees.
是的，然后帕姆说，我们能再商量一分钟吗？对。而这个时候，迈克尔的反应再次显得无比正确。他说，我们真正需要的是工作。我们不需要买断。那些钱是不可能花一辈子的。我们需要的是就业。大家都表示赞同。
Yes, this is his Teach a Man to Fish moment. Yes. Right? So when they come back in, that's what Michael is going to say. You have to hire all of us back. And also, in addition to jobs, Michael wants his seabring again. And his old parking space. But Charles says they don't make seabrings anymore.
是的，这就是他“授人以渔”的时刻。没错。对吧？所以当他们走进来时，迈克尔就会这么说。你们必须把我们所有人都重新雇回去。而且，除了工作之外，迈克尔还想要回他的赛百灵。还有他原来的停车位。但查尔斯说他们已经不生产赛百灵了。
Is that true? Lady, you know I had to know. Oh, I'm so glad you looked this up because I didn't look it up and it has been bothering me. All right. Charles is wrong. They are still making the seabring. This episode aired April of 2009. According to the internet, they made the Chrysler Sebring from 1995 to 2010.
这是真的吗？女士，你知道我肯定得查一下。哦，我太高兴你查了这事，因为我没查，这事一直困扰着我。好吧。查尔斯弄错了。他们还在生产赛百灵。这一集是在2009年4月播出的。根据互联网上的信息，克莱斯勒从1995年到2010年一直在生产赛百灵。
And in looking up this fact, I ended up watching several Sebring commercials over the years. Oh. They have made... You really? I did. We're infested. I think I watched half an hour worth of commercials. Oh my gosh.
而在查阅这个事实的过程中，我最后看了好几个这些年来的赛百灵广告。哦。他们做过……真的吗？我看了。我们被这玩意儿包围了。我想我看了足足半小时的广告。哦天哪。
They made some really interesting choices in their commercials. But there's one I really needed you to hear. It is from 1995. It's the year the car debuted. Can we please play that Sebring commercial? The new Chrysler Sebring was built upon something called the Goldilocks principle. It occurred to us that while most luxury cars were too big, most sport groups were too small. We wanted the Sebring to be, well, just right.
他们在广告里的确做出了一些非常有趣的抉择。但有一个广告我真的很需要你们听听。那是1995年的。那是这款车问世的那一年。我们能播放一下那个赛百灵的广告吗？全新克莱斯勒赛百灵的打造灵感源于所谓的“金发姑娘原则”。我们发现，虽然大多数豪华车都太大了，但大多数跑车又太小了。我们希望赛百灵能做到——嗯，恰到好处。
It not only has a sporty, 24-valve engine and a race-inspired suspension, but it also gives you the luxury of an actual backstop. seat, which means there's enough room for Goldilocks and three or four of her friends. I have to say, okay, so Sam is not with us this week. He's on vacation. Jordan is filling in, and it is like laughing. I can see her laughing at that commercial. Thank you guys. When watching my half an hour of Chrysler commercials for the Seabring, I'd had a glass of wine. And when we got to this one, I literally did a spit take. I was like, what? And the whole time the cars driving through the woods. Okay. Oh, because of Goldie Locks. And the three bears. Yeah. But when they were like, to fit a few of her friends. I was just like, who are these people? That's when Jordan doubled over.
它不仅拥有动感的24气门发动机和赛车风格的悬挂，它还为你提供了实际后排座椅的奢华享受，这意味着这里有足够的空间容纳金发姑娘和她的三四个朋友。我必须说，好吧，萨姆这周没有和我们在一起。他在度假。乔丹代班，她现在笑得不行。我能看到她在那个广告笑出声来。谢谢你们大家。当我为了解赛百灵而观看那半小时的克莱斯勒广告时，我喝了一杯酒。而当我们看到这个时，我真的喷出来了。我就想，什么鬼？而且全程都是汽车在树林里开。好吧。哦，因为金发姑娘。还有三只熊。对。但当他们说到“塞下她的一些朋友”时。我当时就想，这些人都是谁啊？就是那个时候，乔丹笑得直不起腰来。
Oh my gosh. I had to share that. So yes, they still had the seabring. They could have given Michael a seabring in April of 2009. By the way, I want to say, you know my friend Stacy, who I invented the tan baster with? Yes. She drove a seabring. Oh. And it was a lovely car. I have to. to say it was kind of like they're right. It was a really nice combination of a sporty coop, but also roomy. But with a comfortable back seat. I don't know. I never sat in the back seat. Well, Goldilocks would have been happy with it. She could have sat back there. Also, since we brought up Jordan, Jordan did our song parody Total Eclipse of the Fart. Yes, that was Jordan who's saying that. We're very happy to have you. Thank you for filling in for Sam today. Yes, Sam. I brought cake today. So you
哦天哪。我必须分享这个。所以没错，他们当时还在生产赛百灵。他们本可以在2009年4月给迈克尔一辆赛百灵的。顺便说一句，我想说，你知道我的朋友斯黛西吗？就是我和她一起发明“美黑刷”的那位？对。她就开一辆赛百灵。哦。那是一辆很不错的车。我必须得说，这感觉有点像是他们说得对。它确实是动感轿跑车和宽敞空间的完美结合。而且后座很舒服。我不知道。我从来没坐过后排。好吧，金发姑娘会对它很满意的。她可以坐在后排。另外，既然我们提到了乔丹，乔丹制作了我们的恶搞歌曲《放屁的全食》（Total Eclipse of the Fart）。是的，就是乔丹唱的。我们非常高兴有你加入。谢谢你今天代替萨姆。是的，萨姆。我今天带了蛋糕。所以你
missed out on that. I also got it on my sweater as I walked in. Yeah, I noticed it right away when you walked in and I thought, I don't know, it's ketchup or something. You thought I had a messy breakfast. I guess I did. I guess I did. I thought it was left over maybe from the last time you wore it. Jenna. What? I wouldn't leave food on my hoodie and hang it back up. If you didn't notice, you might. Have you never not noticed? It's a pretty big mark right on my boob. I love that my husband, though, didn't say a word as I walked out. Josh, come on. All right. So back to this episode. Would you like to hear how the expense report finished? Yes, please. Because in the script, this is where it would have wrapped up Angela and Andy, their final scene about the expense report.
错过了。我进门的时候还蹭到了我的毛衣上。对，你一进来我就注意到了，我想，我不知道，那是番茄酱还是什么的。你以为我吃早饭弄得很脏。我猜我确实是。我想我是。我还以为那是你上次穿它时留下的呢。珍娜。什么？我才不会把食物留在连帽衫上又把它挂回去呢。如果你没注意到，你可能就会。你从来没有没注意到的时候吗？我的胸口正中央有一个挺大的印记呢。不过我喜欢的是，我走出去的时候，我丈夫竟然一句话也没说。乔什，拜托。好吧。那么回到这一集。你们想听听报销单是怎么收尾的吗？好啊，请吧。因为在剧本里，这就是安迪和安洁拉关于报销单的最后一个场景结束的地方。
And now, with no further rid-ed-d-d-d-do, my revised expense report. The deadlines passed. What? When? When you were saying red-at-de-d-do. it's rid of it ado. I know, I've always been such a fan of it. So delicious! I'm really sad that got cut. Me too. Oh, and as soon as he was like,
现在，废话不多说，这是我修改后的报销单。截止日期已经过了。什么？什么时候？当你在说“废-话-不-多-说”的时候。是“废话不多说”。我知道，我一直都是它的超级粉丝。太棒了！我真的很遗憾这一段被剪掉了。我也是。哦，当他一说——
I just turn around and I don't look at him anymore and he has to walk away. Well, I have some news for Angela. This power that she's had is going to go away because Michael, Pam, and Ryan get their jobs back. Yep. That's the buyout.
我直接转过身去，再也不看他一眼，然后他只好走开。好吧，我有个关于安洁拉的消息要宣布。她一直拥有的这种权力就要消失了，因为迈克尔、帕姆和瑞恩重新得到了他们的工作。没错。这就是买断。
The buyout is that they're, They are all now re-employed by Dunder Mifflin. And I guess, is Charles fired? That was never clear to me. No, I don't think he was fired. He's going to show up in company picnic again. Yeah, no, my understanding, and I reread the script, so sort of what I inferred is that he's just getting reassigned. Well, he's going to be out of Scranton, obviously.
买断的意思是，他们现在全部都被邓德米夫林重新雇用了。我想，查尔斯被解雇了吗？这对我来说一直不太清晰。不，我不认为他被解雇了。他会在“公司野餐”那一集再次出现。对，不，我的理解是，我重新读了剧本，所以我推断出的情况是，他只是被重新分配了工作。好吧，他显然要离开斯克兰顿了。
But originally, Michael says, I want him fired. And David's like, I'm not going to do that, Michael. Yeah. No, he's a good employee. maybe not a good fit right here in the Scranton branch, but he's going to still have his other branches. To manage. To oversee. That's right. That's how I saw it. Okay. Because the whole thing kind of ends with Charles trying to say goodbye, but Michael says, no, no, you're done. And that's the same line that Charles said to Michael in two weeks. Oh. So this is some good Michael Sass. Yeah, Michael held on to that.
但最初，迈克尔说，我要他被开除。而大卫的反应是，我不会那样做的，迈克尔。对。不，他是个好员工。也许不太适合斯克兰顿分公司这里，但他依然会保留他的其他分公司。去管理。去监督。没毛病。我是这么看的。好吧。因为整集的结尾是查尔斯试图告别，但迈克尔说，不，不，你完了。而这正是查尔斯在两周前对迈克尔说过的话。哦。所以这可以说是迈克尔的一次漂亮回击。对，迈克尔一直记着呢。
He really did. And then there's this talking head by Michael that kind of ends the episode where He's just sort of wrapping up this whole storyline of having had this paper company. And Randy shared with us that this was added later. It was not in the original script. They even shot it about two weeks after we shot the rest of this episode. Do you want to know what was in the original shooting draft? Yes, please. Well, there were two final goodbyes to Charles that got cut.
他真的记着呢。然后是迈克尔的一段单人访谈，算是为这一集画上了句号，他在访谈中总结了整个开办这家纸业公司的故事线。兰迪跟我们分享说，这段是后来补拍的。原本的剧本里并没有。他们甚至是在我们拍完这一集其余部分的大约两周后才拍摄这一段的。你们想知道最初的拍摄剧本里有什么吗？好啊，请吧。好吧，有两个最终告别查尔斯的片段被剪掉了。
Any guesses who would want to make sure they said goodbye to Charles, Jenna? I'm imagining it was the ladies who had their ear to the door. who fought over a scarf in the rain. Yes, Angela and Kelly. So in the script, there was this tag. As Charles is leaving, Angela approaches him, and she says, it was an honor. And Charles says, okay then. And he leaves.
大家猜猜谁会确保他们一定要跟查尔斯说再见，珍娜？我猜是那些把耳朵贴在门上的女士们。就是在雨中为了一条围巾大打出手的人。没错，安洁拉和凯莉。所以在剧本里，有这样一个彩蛋。当查尔斯离开时，安洁拉走过去对他说，这是一种荣誉。查尔斯说，好吧。然后他就走了。
Dwight looks out the window as Kelly waits for Charles sitting on the hood of his car sexily. Oh my gosh. As Charles approaches, we see Kelly is sitting on the wrong car. She runs over to Charles but doesn't get there in time. She bangs on the window as he drives off. Charles talking head. Never sleep with coworkers, man. What?
德怀特看着窗外，而凯莉则性感地坐在查尔斯的车前盖上等着他。哦天哪。当查尔斯走近时，我们发现凯莉坐错了车。她朝查尔斯跑去，但没赶上。当他开车离开时，她拍打着车窗。查尔斯单人访谈：永远不要和同事睡觉，老兄。什么？
Wait, what? That's what it ended with. Wait. Co-workers? That's what it said. Never sleep with coworkers, man. Okay. What the heck?
等等，什么？以这个结尾的吗？等等。同事？剧本里就是这么写的。永远不要和同事睡觉，老兄。好吧。搞什么鬼？
That was the ending to this episode. Angela walks up to him, says it was an honor. Kelly tries to sit on his car before he leaves. Hmm. I don't know. Wow. I know. I was like, I have to share that.
这就是这一集的结局。安洁拉走向他，说这是个荣誉。凯莉在他离开前试图坐在他的车上。嗯。我不知道。哇。我懂。当时我想，我必须把这个分享出来。
Okay, well, listen, I'll have you know that in a very early draft, like one of the earliest outlines for this episode, there was another tag. Now, this one didn't even make it into the shooting draft. Okay, because I don't know about this one. Listen to this. My lady, where did you find this? Randy Cordray. Oh, Randy. Here's what it would have been.
好吧，听着，我要告诉你们的是，在非常早期的剧本草稿中，比如这一集最早的大纲之一，还有一个彩蛋。现在，这个彩蛋甚至都没能进入拍摄剧本。好吧，因为我对这个一无所知。听听这个。我的天哪，你在哪找到这个的？兰迪·科德雷。哦，兰迪。原本的剧情是这样的。
and I am so bummed that we did not get to do this. You were going to see Pam, Michael, and Ryan packing up Michael Scott Paper Company, and before they go, Michael is going to give them each a Scotty, which is the Michael Scott Paper Company version of a Dundee. Oh, with a little Scotty dog? No, no, because Michael Scott. Oh. I thought instead of the man with the brief,
我太遗憾我们没能把这一段拍出来了。你会看到帕姆、迈克尔和瑞恩在收拾迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司，在他们离开之前，迈克尔要送给他们每人一个小斯科蒂（Scotty），这就是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司版本的邓迪奖。哦，带着一只小斯科蒂犬？不，不，因为迈克尔·斯科特。哦。我以为不是那个拿公文包的男人。
It was a little Scotty dog. No. I got really excited. It didn't get far enough to know what the statue would be, but they were going to be called Scotty's. Instead of Dundees. Instead of Dundees. And Ryan was going to win one that said great style. And Pam's said boobs.
而是一只小斯科蒂犬。不是。我当时激动坏了。还没发展到知道雕像具体会长什么样的地步，但它们将被命名为“斯科蒂奖”。而不是邓迪奖。而不是邓迪奖。瑞恩会赢得一个写着“绝佳品味”的奖杯。而帕姆的奖杯上则写着“胸部”。
Oh, Michael. So good. Pam got a Scotty. Man, I have my Dundies, both my latest sneakers and my longest engagement. And I so wish I had a Scotty that said boobs. I have my dundies right next to my Emmy and my SAG Awards. I'm so jealous you have a real Emmy. I know.
哦，迈克尔。太棒了。帕姆得到了一个斯科蒂奖。天哪，我有我的邓迪奖，既有我的“最新运动鞋奖”，也有我的“最长订婚奖”。我多么希望我能有一个写着“胸部”的斯科蒂奖啊。我的邓迪奖就摆在我的艾美奖和演员工会奖旁边。我很嫉妒你有一个真正的艾美奖。我知道。
Angela won an Emmy for the webisodes. The accountants. Me and Brian and Oscar won an Emmy, you guys. It was really amazing. But what sits right next to my Emmy that more people want to point out when they come to my house are my two Dundies. Tides ass and she's kind of a bitch. I've said this before. I am really bummed that I did not win an Emmy for Pam, for Pam.
安洁拉因为网络剧《会计师》赢得过艾美奖。我和布莱恩还有奥斯卡赢得过艾美奖，伙计们。真的太棒了。但当人们来到我家时，摆在我的艾美奖旁边、而且更多人想要指出来看的，其实是我的两个邓迪奖。一个叫“屁股大”，另一个叫“她有点像个碧池”。我以前说过这个。我真的很遗憾我没能凭帕姆这个角色赢得艾美奖。
I wanted our gal Pam to win that award. I'll tell you what award Jenna wants to win. What? A Tony Award. So my plan, after my kids are grown, I am going to retire in New York City, and I am going to work hard to get myself in a great Broadway show. I'm going to give the performance of my life. I will vote for you even though I'm not.
我希望我们的好姐妹帕姆能赢得那个奖。我来告诉你们珍娜想赢得什么奖。什么？托尼奖。所以我的计划是，等我的孩子们长大了，我要在纽约市退休，我要努力让自己参演一部精彩百老汇演出。我要献出我一生中最精彩的表演。我一定会投你一票，尽管我不是。
A registered Tony voter. Thank you. And I want to win a Tony. That's the award I want on my shelf more than any other award. I want that for you so desperately. I hope it can happen. I want a Grammy. Ooh, you aren't a singer.
一个有投票权的托尼奖评委。谢谢你。我想赢得一个托尼奖。比起任何其他奖项，那才是我最想放在书架上的奖。我太渴望你能拿到这个奖了。我希望这能成真。我想要一个格莱美奖。哦，你又不是歌手。
I know. Oh, I know. I won a Grammy because, guys, Jenna and I recently found out that with our book, we'll be doing an audiobook. We're very excited about doing the audiobook. and we found out if you really, really crush it, you can get nominated for a Grammy for your audiobook. Amy Poehler got nominated for a Grammy for her audio book. That's right.
我知道。哦，我懂。我赢得过格莱美奖，因为，伙计们，珍娜和不久前我发现，随着我们的书出版，我们将制作一本有声书。我们对制作有声书感到非常兴奋。我们发现如果你真的、真的做得特别棒，你的有声书是可以获得格莱美奖提名的。艾米·波勒就曾因她的有声书获得过格莱美奖提名。没错。
That's right. I want a Grammy. All right. Let's get that effing Grammy. Let's get the Grammy and then get you your Tony. We're going to get those awards this year. You get an award and you guys get an award because you're badasses and you get an award and you get an award. Awards all around.
没错。我想要个格莱美奖。好吧。让我们去拿那个该死的格莱美奖吧。先拿到格莱美，然后再帮你拿下托尼奖。我们今年就要把这些奖项收入囊中。你得一个奖，你们大家也都得一个奖，因为你们都是狠角色，你得一个奖，你也能得一个奖。到处都是奖。
Awards everywhere. This was a great episode. I'm going to make you a Scotty. Oh, will you? Is it going to be a Scotty dog? What's it going to be? It will be my interpretation of what a Scotty would be. And I'm going to make it myself.
到处都是奖。这一集太棒了。我要给你做一个斯科蒂奖。哦，你会吗？那会是一只斯科蒂犬吗？那会是什么样子的？那将是我对斯科蒂奖的个人诠释。而且我要亲手制作它。
So get ready for a second grade skill set of art and crafting coming your way. I will treasure it. I'm going to get out my glue gun. I'm not kidding. I'm going to make this myself. If we gave out awards for our business of office ladies, which is actually... I know what it would be called. Ramblies?
所以请准备好迎接小学二年级水平的工艺美术作品向你袭来吧。我会好好珍藏它的。我要把我的热熔胶枪拿出来。我没开玩笑。我要亲手做这个。如果我们为我们的“办公室女士”业务颁发奖项的话，其实……我知道它应该叫什么。闲聊奖（Ramblies）？
Oh, I was going to say... Ramble? A lady. Oh, you get a lady. You get a lady. Should we give out ladies? We can give out ladies. Okay, Cassie and Jordan are nodding yes. We'll give out some ladies. Oh, let's do it. All right. All right. You guys, thank you so much for listening. We just love you all. And thank you for sending in your comments and your questions and being here every week with us. We hope you have a great day. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second drinks
哦，我本来想说……闲聊（Ramble）？一位女士。哦，你得一个女士奖。你也得一个女士奖。我们应该颁发“女士奖”吗？我们可以颁发女士奖。好的，凯西和乔丹都在点头同意。我们就颁发一些女士奖吧。哦，搞起来。好吧。好吧。伙计们，非常感谢你们的收听。我们爱你们所有人。谢谢你们发送评论和问题，并且每周都陪伴在我们身边。希望你们今天过得愉快。我们下周见。感谢收听办公室女士的第二杯。本期节目最初与Earwolf合作创作。办公室女士是俄狄浦斯（Odyssey）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安洁拉·金斯饰制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔。我们的第二杯
episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
系列节目由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·普法尔。俄狄浦斯的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。办公室女士的混音和母带制作由比尔·舒尔茨完成。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。